[Music]
hi and welcome to next I'm Sean
Darrington group product manager here at
Google Cloud
today I want to cover three different
things one I want to share some storage
best practices around data analytics and
cloud storage
I then want to share a little bit of
insights around stateful workloads in
gke as well as some considerations for
storage and data protection and actually
give you a couple demos and then lastly
I wanted to focus on critical
applications and different design
considerations that you may have for
storage as well as again data protection
so with that let's Jump Right In you
know there are a lot of opportunities to
gain more value from your data but you
have to get the data into Google Cloud
before you can begin to run many of our
analytics options between looker and
vertex Ai and BQ
and so storage transfer service enables
you to do exactly that we have the
opportunity to move data from
on-premises S3 compatible object storage
into Google Cloud we also have the
opportunity to migrate data out of other
Cloud providers into Google Cloud
Storage so once you get the data into
Google Cloud now you have the option to
actually make sure you know who's
accessing what data and where they are
and that's where the integration into
our IAM the identity access management
comes into play you have the
fine-grained multi-tenant capability
between projects to Define who has
access to what data but then we're also
focusing on with cloud storage how can
we make your life simpler simpler in a
variety of ways and that is number one
making it easy from an operational
perspective to get data into cloud
storage instead of going through data
migrations and changing from structured
to unstructured or vice versa
things like Hadoop and Spark we actually
give you the opportunity to use the same
file system structure hdfs but now you
can just transition simply use GS colon
slash and begin to run your analytics
from there again making it really easy
to begin to gain value from the
information you have but we're also
focusing on how you can take advantage
of optimizing your costs across multiple
storage classes within cloud storage
whether you're looking at standard or
nearline or cold line or archive you
have a single set of apis across all of
those so from an application design
perspective you have one bucket one set
of apis regardless of which storage
class is actually satisfying those
requests but we're also focusing on not
only the costs and design application
but also the response time one of the
most important things from an analytics
perspective is can I get consistent
millisecond response time from standard
all the way down to Archive and with
Google Cloud Storage you can do exactly
that
the other thing we're doing is focusing
on operational Simplicity that is every
organization is trying to reduce costs
over time with auto class we give you
the opportunity to hit the easy button
to turn on an entire Bucket Level
whether it be millions billions or
trillions of objects you have the
opportunity to turn on auto class which
will now migrate objects from one class
of storage to another by policy without
any intervention and as we migrate
storage from standard all the way down
to Archive
there are no deletion fees or retrieval
fees that you may have from an early
deletion request of data that might be
resident for only 30 days instead of 60.
these are all things that make it very
easy to optimize the storage costs and
where those objects are over time and
this is something that we've recently
announced and it'll be excitingly
available in Q4
the other consideration is how do you
get compute as close to the data as
possible and with cloud storage you can
certainly have a single region and run
all the analytics in that region but
oftentimes you want higher levels of
availability if something impedes or
interrupts that operation in a given
region and so with cloud storage we've
had the opportunity to Define dual
region replication for years strongly
consistent replication with a recovery
time objective that you can basically
design a continental scale bucket
regardless of where the data is being
served from the application doesn't know
but what we've done recently is actually
introduced enhanced options so now you
have nine options for Regions within
three continents to choose for that dual
region configuration and you can
continue to use that replication that's
strongly consistent if you want to so if
your objects are in in compute in region
B need to be retrieved from region a
that can easily be done but if you need
an extra level of availability you can
also look at the optional turbo
replication this gives you a 15 minute
RPO SLA
so now combined with dual region
replication you have a recovery time
objective of zero for your Continental
scale bucket but you also have now a
recovery Point objective of 15 minutes
and last but not least as you look at
this design from Storage transfer
service on the left hand side getting
the data into Google Cloud Storage
looking at how do you replicate cloud
storage across two different regions the
different options you have for analytics
whether it be vertex AI or bigquery you
need to think about performance
everybody wants their data more quickly
and that's where we come into play with
our cloud storage option you have the
option to scale that performance almost
as much as you need to we have retail
customers today that are using our cloud
storage with analytics that are
exceeding 10 terabytes per second of
throughput now not everybody's going to
need that much throughput but if you do
it's an option to design your
application that way and last but not
least regardless of what type of
analytic workload you're using bigquery
or vertex AI this is all supported with
cloud storage
so many times shifting gears to gke many
times organizations are looking at
stateless workloads and that's been the
way that most people have been using
that however we're seeing more and more
customers thinking about stateful
workloads where if the Pod goes down or
that namespace goes down you can't just
regenerate that data so you have to
think about things differently and
that's where backup for gke comes into
play this is now an offering that we've
recently made generally available it's
integrated directly within the cloud
console that you can choose to protect
your kubernetes environment in a few
Mouse clicks protect it locally protect
it across another continent just depends
upon what level of recoverability you
want to protect against and this is
something that we do from a very
fine-grained policy definition
perspective so whether you're running
and supporting persistent disk you have
the option to protect a single
application multiple namespaces or the
entire cluster if you want to and we
have application consistency as well for
many of the options so you can have a
crash consistent backup for some but in
some cases you actually want an
application consistent backup some of
the policies that we've actually
introduced and give you options for
actually protected against ransomware as
well so time lock is a very popular
feature that people use to actually
apply to a given policy that says
regardless of who wants to delete that
backup it cannot be deleted until a time
lock expires of say 90 days so
ransomware may try to but it won't be
able to
so now I want to introduce Manu batra
who's going to do a demonstration of
backup for gke
for the backup demo we're going to do
I'm going to create two clusters one a
primary cluster called postgres cluster
we're going to create the cluster in a
rapid Channel with 1.24
next we'll enable the backup for GK
add-on
we'll select specific machine types in
this case E2 standard 2.
and our cluster is created now let's
create the secondary cluster
can in Rapid Channel with 1.24
with similar machine types enable backup
for GK so now we have two clusters one
for backup other we're going to restore
that backup
let's log into our primary cluster
deploy postgres
let's log into postgres Creator table
and insert some data
let's insert learning gkspun database on
GK are easy
so when we take a backup and restore
we'll check if the same table with the
data can be retrieved on the restore
cluster so now let's go to backup 4gk
create a new backup plan
we have two clusters
we select the cluster we want to backup
we will give this backup plan a name
it's a postgres plan backup plan we
select the target we want to store the
data
and we have the backup plan let's take
an instantaneous sort of quick backup
this is a manual backup we'll give this
backup a name
and let's check if our backup's done our
backup has succeeded now let's walk
through the process to restore let's
create a restore plan
let's select where you want to restore
we want to restore all the namespaces in
the backup
we want to create new volumes on backup
so we're selecting all the options for
creating a backup plan let's keep
default for restoration rules
now let's go back to backup for gke we
have a new backup for gke ReStore plan
for postgres
we have a new backup now let's restore
this backup
with the plan we just created into the
new cluster
as you can see our restore was
successful
now let's log into the new cluster and
see if the data that we created on the
primary cluster and all the config has
been recreated into this new cluster
so my postgres workload is recreated
onto the postgres cluster restore
all my configs story classes settings
PVC claims are also restored
and the data that I took a backup for is
already available so that was a quick
demo thank you so much great thank you
so much Manu
staple workloads obviously have to be
protected via backup for GK as we just
described however if you're thinking
about multi-writer applications
oftentimes pods need access to
consistent storage they need access to
persistent storage and that's where file
store comes into play file store is an
NFS managed storage service that you can
use for gke and we have been able to do
this for a while we'll see it with the
CSI driver the container storage
interface driver we have some new news
that we've announced regarding file
store Enterprise and some options there
but if you think about how you can have
tens dozens or even hundreds or
thousands of PODS accessing the same
data that's what we provide with file
store it provides highly available
storage so if Pod 1 goes down pod 2
still has access to the exact same NFS
Mount point and from an operational
perspective file store supports
non-destructive upgrades so as we add
more features over time we incrementally
improve file store that upgrade is going
to be non-disruptive to your environment
you don't want to plan for downtime when
you're when you're doing this this just
happens in the background
the other option depending upon the
level of applications you're running and
the availability requirements is files
for Enterprise actually has a 49 SLA
that Regional SLA ensures the data is
replicated across three zones within
that region
the new option that we've introduced
with filester Enterprise is multi-share
this is the option for you to take a
file store instance let's say one
terabyte and carve it up into smaller
shares to provision across multiple pods
so now you can provision as little as 10
gigabytes per pod that your admins need
very simple to do you create a storage
class then your your gke admins can then
create PVS and begin to consume that but
let's dive into a demonstration and take
a look at this in action
in this demonstration I want to show you
file store Enterprise in the new
multi-share capabilities to use with
your gke clusters so let's get started
so first of all we're actually going to
create a cluster in GK we're actually
going to use the autopilot capabilities
to make things simplified I'm going to
call this cluster stateful cluster I'm
also going to use a rapid channel for
the file store multi-share feature here
this is going to enable us to not only
create the cluster but then make sure
that the cluster is properly connected
so I'm going to click create here and
now I'm going to begin to configure the
manage storage with file store this is
going to use a CSI driver the container
storage interface for this
it's going to make it really simple to
do I'm also going to show you the yaml
file here for the storage class this
shows you that storage class is using
file store Enterprise which is important
but you also want to make sure the
multi-share is set to true this is going
to give you that functionality to have
the smaller shares down to 10 gigabytes
if you will within filester Enterprise
now
once I do that now I'm going to actually
run the PVC yaml file and you'll
actually see that I'm going to do this
with a single persistent volume in in
this provisioning process and eventually
be bound to the cluster now you can do
this with multiple PVS if you want to
but in this instance I'm just going to
do one PB and 100 Gig of the multi-share
within file store Enterprise
uh now I'm not actually showing you some
of the yaml files for the reader and
writer deployments uh the reader pods
are actually going to be exposed by the
load balancer for users to view and this
is what I'm going to actually show you
at the end here to show you how the
multirider capability of file store
supports this we're going to just choose
20 Rider pods these will all
simultaneously write to the same shared
storage every 30 seconds so in this case
it's writing to that 1pb file store
Enterprise that I created every 30
seconds so I'll refresh it so you can
see that increases also skip the the
ammo file for the load balancer this
basically just exposes uh the reader pod
to file store and here's the URL that I
clicked on
to actually show you that I've got 20 20
Rider pods writing and as I refresh this
you can actually see that it's recording
all the writers that are writing to the
shared NFS file system the Enterprise
that I just created it'll actually show
you when I refresh this at the same
writer host names match each other as
you go through this and that's as easy
as it is to use file store Enterprise
and multi-share capabilities
great
the last area I want to share with you
is some best practices with storage and
critical applications
one of the things that we've been
focusing on with critical applications
is our block storage offering persistent
disk we've recently announced hyperdisk
hyperdisc is the next Generation
persistent disk that we've kind of
rethought what Block Story should look
like in the cloud
we think it should be able to be
dynamically provisioned with block
storage and particularly hyperdisc we
want to give you three dials if you will
to turn iops throughput and capacity
based upon how you need to size your
application you can tune all those
independently but we also want to give
you the ability to tune those across a
wide variety of workloads from
throughput driven workloads to iops
driven workloads and we want to make it
easy for you to manage capacity at scale
managing 10 terabytes of data is very
different than managing a petabyte of
block storage
and that's where we've recently
introduced hyperdisc Extreme as the name
implies it's going to satisfy the most
demanding iops driven database workloads
like sap Hana and that's going to be
suited for a percentage of applications
but really the top tier percent of
applications we're introducing and
announcing hyperdisc balance as well
this is going to support the widest
range of applications from throughput
oriented to iops driven
and last but not least we have hyperdisc
throughput as the name implies those
that need gigabytes per second of
performance not necessarily iops driven
performance workloads so all of these
we've rolled out over time hyperdisc
extreme will be in preview this quarter
but underlying all these is really about
how you can optimize the storage
utilization with storage pools
with storage pools
you can think about thin provisioning as
we're used to in the on-premises world
now brought to the cloud so you can
create a pool storage allocate that
storage to multiple servers and
essentially over provision storage and
only use what you need to use thin
provisioning brought to the cloud with
storage pools but let's take a look at
what this looks like in a SQL Server
provisioning environment
today with persistent disk on the left
hand side there are a variety of steps
you need to go through different
persistent disk options have performance
characteristics you have to size the VM
accordingly and you have licensing
implications oftentimes associated with
the vcpus that you're provisioning for
that application
and if you get it right on day one
that's great but if it changes over time
you have to go back and re-chain
reprovision performance and reprovision
persistent disk that can oftentimes
cause a lot of complications
if you look at the right hand side
hyperdisc dramatically simplifies this
you have those three knobs iops
throughput and capacity to turn on day
one to provision what you need based
upon the application requirements and
size the VM to what the application
needs not what the block storage needs
additionally over time after month six
or two month 12 you can actually
dynamically change that performance
characteristic IOP throughput and or
capacity as needed
so one of the things that hybrid extreme
is very well suited for is the most
demanding database workloads like sap
Hana this is an architecture for sap
Hana that's highly available within a
region but then also replicated to a
second region for full Disaster Recovery
as you see the Hana database is
supported with hyperdisc extreme doing
synchronous replication with HSR now
that's covering the database side of
things but what about the shared files
those combination of media files app
server Etc binaries that need to be used
for sap that's where file store
Enterprise comes into play file store
has four nines of a regional SLA
availability which means that we're
synchronously replicating across three
zones within a region so if the media
server is in zone B goes down the media
servers in zone a have access to the
exact same data recovery time objective
of zero recovery Point objective of zero
just like the HRS replication of the
database layer but thinking about the
database and the app and the shared file
use case is important we also need to
think about backup and ER for the entire
system and that's where Google clouds
backup and Dr that we recently announced
comes into play this is one of the
things that now within directly within
the cloud console you can choose and set
a policy to choose gcbe GCE other
applications and databases seamlessly
protect locally and or remotely so
combination of hyperdisc file store and
Google Cloud backup and Dr you can
protect the entire critical application
environment and with backup in Dr we
have a continuous incremental backup
strategy so you're going to maximize
that storage utilization
either in region or across region in
addition to having very fast recovery
time objectives based upon that
incremental forever backup policy with
that thank you so much for joining me
today please check out Google Cloud's
Channel on YouTube for additional Tech
demonstrations and deep dives into many
of the Technologies and topics that I
touched on today
[Music]